voici patrick huard en 1997 il se
demande pourquoi les gens regardent ce
qui se trouve dans leurs mouchoirs 17
ans plus tard gad elmaleh dit
sensiblement la même chose voire rien
joue un mec se bouger un regard pourquoi
je sais du copiage enfin on va le dire
c'est vraiment yoko pied il ya pris du
matériel que d'autres m'ont écrit c'est
quoi c'est important voyage elles ont un
forfait voix yens dans ce nouveau
montage vidéo de 13 minutes
il ya aussi plusieurs ressemblances
entre des blagues de martin matte dany
boon dieudonné richard preuve jerry
seinfeld et celle plus récente racontée
par gad elmaleh ou est-ce que c'est
l'âge et où elle a la queue ou où
certains gags sont tellement spécifique
à villejuif gad elmaleh à un succès
international en français comme en
anglais je veux avoir un passeport
canadien né au maroc
il s'est installé au québec à l'âge de
17 ans pour ensuite mettre le cap sur
paris évident citoyen canadien il a été
décoré chevalier de l'ordre du québec en
son équipe n'a pas répondu à notre
demande d'entrevue sauf que ce qui est
le plus accablant pour lui c'est la
récurrence
si ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné on
ne peut pas penser que ces coïncidences
mais que nous dit la loi à propos du
plagiat dans ce cabinet d'avocats
spécialisé en droit des arts on ne veut
pas commenter la sphère elmaleh mais on
nous répond ceci tant que la loi sur le
droit d'auteur pour évaluer du plagiat
sont veut regarder si une reproduction
de la totalité ou d'une partie
importante d'une oeuvre la loi définit
pas qu'est ce que c'est qu'une partie
importante donc on va vraiment faire une
évaluation au cas par cas
on a découvert qu'il faisait sur des
coûts plein d'autres criques ce n'est
pas la première fois que gad elmaleh est
qualifié de clages hier à chaque fois
l'humoriste eux préfèrent plutôt dire
qu'il est inspiré par d'autres
humoristes de dire que je m'inspire de
jerry seinfeld c'est comme dire en
politique s'il était là son secret de
polichinelle face à la polémique
gad elmaleh n'est plus le bienvenu au
bordel comedy club de montréal
c'est michael qui a décidé de
qui demande la question est ce qu'on
fait c'est un mouvement de le baril pour
protéger une tête justement les autres
humoristes comme soir sur ses spectacles
après cette première vidéo d'une virale
une autre pourrait être mise en ligne la
semaine prochaine par le youtube est
reconnu comme et cage qui veut et je
cite interpeller le public sur la
situation du plagiat en humour ici oui
fait depuis mai radio-canada morin